for me I fell out of love with gaming at  the start of the pandemic with the  lockdown I obviously started playing  games a little bit too much and relied  on it more than I ever did before and  with the releases of new games that I  was excited for but honestly just fell  short that were blatantly unfinished  with a full price tag still attached to  it I found myself angry with the gaming  industry as a whole when elder ring was  announced I was hyped up just like  everybody else but I was also terrified  I really did not want to see from  software release an unfinished game and  we just have another hyped up release  disappoint us yet again this game was  gonna be it for me if a developer that I  looked up to as the creator of some of  the best games ever made would also fall  into the greedy fire pit that the gaming  industry is seemingly turning into today  I told myself that I would be done I  would no longer spend my time and money  playing video games